من شمال سوريا رائد صالح مدير الدفاع
المدني سيد رائد الصالح ما اخر ما وقفت
عليه فرق الدفاع المدني في الشمال السوري
من احصاء لعدد الضحايا والمصابين
والمانكوبين جراء الزلزال الذي ضرب هذه
المناطق
حقيقه النهائيه كما تحدثت قبل قليل
فقدوا ارواحهم تحت الانقاض عدد المصابين
2600 وصل وما زالت يعني نحن نحدث الارقام
بشكل مستمر على معرفاتنا الرسميه ولكن
يعني الى الان
لم تصل هناك ايه مساعدات لشمال غرب سوريا
وهذا يعني حقيقه عاريه جديد يجب ان يتم
الحديث عنه حقيقه ويجب ان يتم ان ان يتم
التسطيط الضوء على هذا الامر بان شمال
سوريا شمال غرب سوريا هناك مدن جنديرس
وحارم وسلقين وارمناز واعزمارين وجسر
الشغور وادلب وكثير وسرمده ودانه والاثارب
وكثير من المناطق الاخرى المنكوبه التي
تدمرت بشكل كامل بدون وصول اي فرق انقاذ
لوليدون ارسال ايه كلها جميع هذه
الاجراءات هي تخضع للبيروقراطيه تخضع
لعمليه بصراحه
البروتوكولات الكاذبه التي وضعت من قبل
الامم المتحده وغيرها الى الان امم تحدي
لم تتواصل ولم ترسل اصلا مساعدات الى شمال
غرب سوريا وعلق بعملياتها الانسانيه ولم
تتواصل معنا او حتى الاتحاد الاوروبي
حقيقه هذا عار يركب هذه
المؤسسات التي
قررت ان تتعامل او تاخذ موافقه من النظام
السوري اصلا من هؤلاء المدنيين هم من
شردهم وقتلهم نظام السوري
ودعمهم موجودين الان في شمال سوريا وهم
الان يريدون ان يتحكم النظام السوري بحتى
في المساعدات التي ممكن ان تصل لهم حقيقه
مؤسسات الامم المتحده هي عار على على
الامم والشعوب العالم كلها هي
الان جديد في في العالم لانه الى الان لا
يوجد اي استجابه من الامم المتحده لشمال
غرب سوريا وجميعهم يريدون موافقه نظام
مجرم بحق شعبه لكي يرسلوا المساعدات
والجميع يتكلم عن عن حقيقه ما يحدث نحن
فعليا نتطلع الى الى تحرك دولي يعني هناك
دول قليله جدا يعني تواصلت معنا ومنهم
دوله قطر مشكوره وهم سيقدمون المساعده
ويقدمون الاغاثه لاهلنا حقيقه يعني انا لا
اعلم لا اعلم ما هي الكلمات التي ممكن ان
التقيها حتى اتحدث بهذا الموضوع ولكن نحن
في شمال سوريا دول يعني دوله كتركه تعاني
من صعوبات لوجسيه وتامين معدات وهناك وصول
لعدد كبير من الفرق ونحن حقيقه لا نلومهم
ولا ولا نحسدهم بالعكس نحن نقف مع اهلنا
في تركيا ونقد مع لانه لانه ايضا في في
تركيا هناك كثير من السوريين تحت الانقاذ
نحن نقف معهم ولو كان حتى في امكاننا ان
نرسل تركيا كنا سنرسل ولكن نحن لم ياتي
احد لمساعدتنا حتى نستطيع ومعلومات عن
بقاء 700 من العالقين تحت الاقد بوحدها
سيد رائد الصالح ولكن قبل ان تحدثنا عن كل
تلك الصعوبات التي اشرت عليها اليها في
عمليات الانقاذ وندرت المساعدات ايضا يشير
الى هذه الحصيله الجديده التي تظهر على
شاشتنا والتي تقدمها اداره الكوارث
التركيه والتي تقول ان عدد قتل هذا
الزلزال ارتفع الى
6,234 قتيلا وعدد المصابين الى
37,000 واحد عشر مصابا جراء هذا الزلزال
اذا الذي ضرب تركيا وضرب سوريا كذلك
والحصيله ايضا هناك مرشحه للارتفاع امام
بقاء هذه الاعداد الكبيره من العالقين تحت
الانقاذ كما ذكرت لك سيد رائد صالح 700 في
رف ادلب وحدها ماذا عن باقي المدن التي
تضررت جراء هذا الزلزال ربما تقديراتكم
لما يمكن الوصول اليه من العالقين حتى في
ظل الامكانيات
ربما القليله والمتواضعه والتي ربما لا
تناسب حجم الكارثه هنا
حقيقه
يعني دعني اذا اردنا ان نتحدث عن الارقام
لا يمكن الان كل الارقام التي تظهر هي
ارقام مؤقته لمده خمس دقائق وبعد خمس
دقائق
ستتغير الارقام حتما في يعني كما تحدثت
لحتى في تركيا وفي سوريا انا اعلم مئات
الاشخاص انهم شخصيا لا يوجد تواصل معه في
تركيا هم من اصدقائي او من اقاربي من
مدينتي انا معظمها ناجحه اصلا الى الى
تركيا الى
هاتاي ايضا في في شمال غرب سوريا الان لا
نستطيع ان نحسن هناك عائلات باكملها تحت
الالقاب نحن يعني عمليه البحث الاوليه
نسال من موجود تحت الانقاذ ولكن اذا لم
يكن هناك موجود احد من العائله او احد من
البناء كامل جميعهم تحت الالقاب فنحن لا
نستطيع ان نقدر العدد بشكل دقيق او بشكل
اقرب الى الدقه لانه فعليا لن يتم الارقام
النهائيه ولن يتم التاكد من حجم الارقام
النهائيه بدون ان ان ننهي كافه اعمال بحث
اعمال انتشار الضحايا من تحت الانقاذ حتى
نستطيع الارقام ستكون كبيره جدا مع مرور
الوقت حقيقه سيكون الامر صعبا يعني انا
اعتقد ان الارقام تتصل بالالاف لاعداب
الضحايا يعني هناك يمكن ان تتجاوز العشره
الاف ولكن نحن لا نستطيع الان ان نقدر
يعني انا اليوم 2082 ممكن بعد ساعه يصبح
الرقم اكبر او بعد عشر دقائق سيكون رقم
اكبر لانه بشكل كل ما تقدم الوقت يتم
انتشار ضحايا ويتم انتشار اشخاص ويتم جمع
الاحصائيات حقيقه نعاني من مشاكل
اللوجستيه كبيره جدا
لدينا عشرات الجثث موجوده بالمستشفيات لا
احد يمكن التعرف عليها لدينا لا يوجد
اماكن لحفظ هذه الجسم اصلا يعني نحن ندير
حقيقه يعني ماساه كبيره جدا لا نعلم يعني
نحن نريد ان يتم التعرف على هذه الجساس لم
نستطيع حقيقه استاجرنا برادات سيارات حتى
نحفظ الجثث البارحه
واستاجرنا
اليات
لمتابعه هناك يعني لم يقف معنا كفرق دفاع
مدني الا السوريين المدنيين الذين اطلقنا
النداء لكل السوريين كل من يمتلك اهله كل
من يمتلك معدي تساعدنا يجب ان يوصلها الى
مكان العمل وحقيقه كانت استجابه عظيمه من
اهلنا في سوريا وكانت استجابه كبيره لذلك
واستجاب كبير من المنظمات
السوريين نعاني من صعوبات لوجيسيين يعاني
من صعوبات تقنيه ونعاني حتى في موضوع
الاتصالات يعني موضوع نحن في اول البال في
اول يوم من الزلزال فقدر الاتصال مع معظم
الفرق في مناطق كثيره لم نكن نملك
الاتصالات حتى لم نكن نستطيع ان يعني
واجهنا حتى في اداره العمليات وفي اداره
وصول حتى المعدات والاليات هذه الظروف حتى
بهذه الامكانيات تستمر عمليات البحث
والانقاذ هناك في عموم هذه المناطق
المتضرره في الشمال السوري شكرا جزيلا لك
رائد صالح مدير الدفاع المدني كنت معنا من
شمال سوريا